ciao maryners e benvenuti in un nuovissimo video
oggi un video un pó particolare ho
deciso di farlo perché tanti di voi che
mi seguono su instagram hanno notato che
ho tanti tanti occhiali da sole ma
quello che non sapete è che in realtà io
gli occhiali da sole li colleziono sono
piena di occhiali da sole
quindi ho deciso di aprire lo scatolone
dei miei occhiali da sole e farveli
vedere non li faccio vedere tutti perché
sono veramente tanti ma vi faccio vedere
insomma i miei preferiti
prima di iniziare a farvi vedere i miei
occhiali vi ricordo se non l'avete
ancora fatto di iscrivervi al mio canale
e di cliccare sulla campanella vicino al
tasso d'iscrizione così non vi perderete
nessuno dei miei prossimi video partiamo
subito con la prima categoria
la prima categoria non poteva non essere
il primo amore ebbene si questo occhiale
qua di versace rosa è stato il mio primo
occhiale firmato avrò avuto forse non so
14 o 15 anni non mi ricordo bene e avevo
fatto delle storie per averlo
incredibili me l'avevano regalato
probabilmente per il mio compleanno e
ovviamente era l'unico occhiale di
versace rosa quindi se dovevo scegliere
non scelgo quello rosa tra l'altro adesso
questa forma questo modello questo fumé
che vedete quando sfuma dallo scuro al
più chiaro è tornato stra di moda cioè
tutti i trapper hanno questi occhiali
ragazzi quindi prossimamente marina bb yeah
questa è una delle mie categorie
preferite perché quando ero un po più
piccolina avevo dei gusti un po più
eccentrici ero un po più tamarra e non solo
in fatto di vestiti ma anche e
soprattutto di occhiali anche perché
anni fa c'erano degli occhiali veramente
super tamarri andavano stra di moda il
più tamarro della storia e questo è la
mascherina di dior non mi ricordo
esattamente l'anno in cui andava di moda
ma so solo che se ti giravi con questa
mascherina tu eri fico giustamente chi
non se li ricordo chi non era ancora
nato dirá ma cos'é sta porcheria ragazzi
che ve devo di andava di moda piaceva un
sacco era proprio da figa da top adoro
ma non me lo sono comprato io è stato un
regalo di seconda mano di mia cugina che
era molto più grande di me e ne aveva
due paia oro e argento visto che usava di più
quello oro ha detto bene quello argento
visto che ti piace te lo regalo
per il tuo compleanno io ero tipo il regalo
del secolo
e poi c'è il carrera bianco che è una
garanzia se vuoi essere tamarro perché
con tanti modelli di carrera non so se
va ancora di moda adesso
però se tu ce li hai di altri colori sei
normale se tu ce l'hai bianco sei
ufficialmente tamarro e io di che colore
ce l'ho secondo voi ma non sapete la
storia che c'è dietro perché questo
occhiale qui non è mio il primo anno in
cui mi sono trasferita a milano ero in
una casa con altri studenti
questo mio coinquilino che era molto
tamarro aveva questo paio di occhiali
e a me piacevano un sacco quindi avevamo
fatto un change un cambio io non mi
ricordo
l'occhiale che gli ho dato in cambio sta
di fatto che ero molto contenta di questo
scambio e non l'ho mai messo però questo
occhiale devo dire la verità è stata una moda passeggera
l'avrò messo forse due volte dopo di che mi è servito solo per riempire questa
categoria purtroppo come nel tag del
bikini non è che ci sono solo gli
occhiali belli che mi stanno bene che
non hanno problemi
infatti questa categoria è la categoria
dei larghi perché io li ho comprati e
li ho slargati totalmente quindi cosa
succede guardate un po
senza le mani si tolgono pazzesco l'ho
portato a stringere ovviamente si può
stringere ma comunque è troppo largo per
me voi dite ti sei svegliato tardi li
potevi provare quando te li sei comprati
questi qui sono forse ancora più larghi
guardate addirittura come si aprono le
stanghette guardate che bello prima di
farvi vedere gli occhiali che
appartengono a questa categoria dovete
sapere che questi occhiali non li ho
comprati in un negozio vintage ma sono
degli occhiali di mia mamma
in primis c'è questo qui che io amo amo
l'ho messo tantissimo
magari nelle storie instagram vi posterò
qualche foto con questo occhiale lo
mettevo addirittura la sera per uscire
cioè con la gente che mi chiedeva che
problemi hai ma io li amavo c'era un periodo
proprio che non riuscivo a
staccarmeli di dosso poi ci sono questi
qui di christian dior che sono molto
matrix reloaded
no son ritornati mi dicono dalla
regia sobri eleganti poi ci sono
questi jill sander viola viola non è un
colore che amo ma in questo caso mi
piace molto da quella nota di intrigante
ametista parole a caso qua dovere sapere ragazzi che
la moda è parole a caso perché tipo tu
cosa dici di questi occhiali
tartaruga tartarugati un pó un pó da
spolverare che son pieni di polvere il
bello è quello degli occhiali vintage
che magari appunto perché li rimetti
perché sono tornati quelli che magari andavano
di moda negli anni sessanta e negli anni settanta
ritornano nel 2020 la moda è ciclica la
moda è ritorno questa categoria è una
categoria che mi sta molto a cuore anche
perché sono tutti occhiali che hanno
fatto parte della mia vita e li ho usati
tantissimo proprio perché li ho usati
tantissimo non ce l'hanno fatta
questo occhiale questo occhiale ha fatto
veramente la storia l'ho utilizzato
tantissimo e mi è dispiaciuto un sacco
quando si è sfasciato ma dedicherei un
momento speciale una parentesi a questi
due occhiali entrambi di marc jacobs
perché loro sono stati gli occhiali di
una delle estati più belle e divertenti
della mia vita
gallipoli 2011 durante l'estate 2011
appunto ho lavorato come pr ragazza
immagine e ballerina ho fatto insomma
una stagione estiva appunto in puglia a
gallipoli è stato divertentissimo ma
soprattutto ero sempre sotto il sole
quindi non ci crederete mai ma ero
abbronzata e quindi gli occhiali da sole
non sono stati fondamentali di più e la
cosa che vi giuro ragazzi mi fa venire
la pelle d'oca è che c'è ancora la
sabbia qua dentro sono completamente
rovinati perché veramente ne hanno
viste di ogni ma sono quelli a cui sono
più affezionata perché veramente mi
ricordano quell'estate questo
qua è ancora leggermente a parte qualche
graffio sulla lente questo qua e proprio
scrostato sabbia
forse c'è ancora proprio dell'acqua di
mare dentro
questa categoria la adoro l'ho chiamata i
2000 ma in realtà volevo chiamarla anche
paris in onore a paris hilton perché
sono proprio quegli occhiali che si
metteva sempre lei appunto negli anni
2000 tutti appunto molto tondeggianti
grossi ma ovali questo in particolare
di jimmy choo ed è pazzesco
qua non so se si riesce a vedere hanno
la stanghetta pitonata e niente
sono veramente top e sono molto simili a
quest altro paio di occhiale che è
praticamente uguale ma ha le stanghette
bianche questo ancora più 2000 proprio
e poi c'è questo qui che è leggermente
più attuale perché é un total black ma ha
sempre questa forma tondeggiante questo é
di prada e l'ho messo tantissimo credo che
l'estate fosse 2010 io direi solo una
parola adoro ma poi ho messo apposta
questo top perché sapevo che sarebbe
arrivato questo momento questo
abbinamento occhiale e top veramente
pazzesco questi tra l'altro gli ho messi
in questa categoria sobri ma sono in
realtà vintage di mia mamma quindi erano
in mezzo tra le due categorie visto che
la vintage ne ha già troppi ho detto li
metto nella sobrietà perché comunque la
sobrietà prima di tutto
poi abbiamo questo qua specchiato
gianfranco ferrè anni ottanta favola
favola l'ho messo anche tantissimo e
tutti mi guardavano come fossi un alieno
a parte gli scherzi al di là del fatto
che io amo l'oro sì ok sono impegnativi
però cioè se tu hai un amica lei dentro
si può specchiare
concluderei questo video con un oro nero
l'avete già visto in qualche tiktok
pubblicato di recente sobrio sobrio nel
senso che oltre a essere oro nero ha una
catena che unisce le stanghette comunque
stella mccartney
proprio top level con questo
fantastico occhiale io terminerei qui il
video spero che vi sia piaciuto mi
raccomando importantissimo fatemi sapere
con un commento qui sotto
quale categoria avete preferito oppure
quale occhiale da sole avete preferito
mi raccomando mettete un bel like se
volete un altro video
insomma di questa tipologia magari con
dei vestiti delle scarpe insomma fatemi
sapere cosa vi piacerebbe vedere e
soprattutto seguitemi su tutti gli altri
social quindi instagram tiktok e
facebook
per vedere tutte le mie foto e i video
con questi fantastici occhiali e con tutti
gli altri con quelli che non ci sono qua
nel video perché ce ne sono altri
ovviamente io vi mando un bacione e
top adoro ci vediamo al prossimo video